hogwarts legacy has been delayed to 2022
and i think there's a chance
avalanche ends up dropping support for
the ps4
and xbox one it's a question many of you
have been asking and in today's video
we'll break down that potential decision
and what i think is going to happen
people of the internet retro raconteur
here if we're meeting for the first time
i'm just the dad who loves games and the
stories they tell
we post videos every week here on
youtube and if you want to stay up to
date on all the latest hogwarts legacy
news theories and discussion then this
is the channel for you
despite a very rough year in 2020
hogwarts legacy fans always had
something to look forward to with the
game scheduled to release in 2021.
unfortunately those hopes were shattered
when avalanche and wb
announced the decision to delay the game
all the way to 2022
i've already made a couple of videos on
the subject but one of the questions
i've continued to see
over and over again is what this lengthy
delay could mean
for the ps4 and xbox one versions of the
game
now when hogwarts legacy was officially
unveiled back in september 2020 it was
confirmed to be in development for pc
ps4 ps5 xbox one and the xbox series
family of consoles
pretty much everything except the
nintendo switch gets in on the action
now to be completely clear as far as the
official word from avalanche and wb goes
we have heard absolutely nothing about
cancellation of old platforms if you go
to the website right now
at least at the time of recording this
video that is ps4
and xbox one are still in fact listed at
the bottom of the website along with the
others
now we know the game has been in
development since at least
2018 so it's safe to say they entered
this process planning for this to be a
ps4 and xbox one game
who knows how much behind the scenes
knowledge they had of ps5 and xbox
series x but we can be fairly confident
this game didn't start with those
systems at the forefront of their minds
when hogwarts legacy was originally
slated for 2021 releasing on
all these systems made perfect sense the
ps5 and xbox series x would have only
been out for one year and a very supply
constrained year at that
it made perfect financial sense to
release the games on both current gen
and last gen tech but now that it's set
for 2022 instead
should things change i put this question
out to you guys in one of our recent
videos and you all had a lot of great
arguments on both sides of this
i gotta say most of you were also super
respectful of one another in the
comments and i can't even begin to
describe how happy that makes me so
thank you all so much for that and
let's keep it going on this video as
well it's not too late to share your
thoughts on this if any of these
arguments i'm about to discuss
really resonate with you then be sure to
leave a comment and let me know how you
feel about all this so those who were
okay with the game dropping last gen
support most often cited the overall
quality of hogwarts legacy as their
primary concern
the theory here would be that without
having to worry about the older tech of
ps4 and xbox one
the devs could instead focus solely on
the more powerful hardware and thus do
even more great things within the game
itself
people on the other side argue that
dropping ps4 and xbox one support
wouldn't be fair to owners of those
consoles who haven't been able to
upgrade yet either due to supply
constraints or financial reasons
i mean we did have a very tough year due
to a worldwide pandemic
numerous people losing their jobs and
having less disposable income
so while the unique nature of 2020 makes
hogwarts legacy in somewhat of a
different position
it's definitely not the first time that
a game has been in a spot like this
it's a question that gets brought up
with each new console generation as devs
and publishers are faced with the
decision of how long they should
continue to support
old hardware let's take a look at some
of the heavy hitters such as madden and
call of duty you'll find they're
typically released on previous
generation hardware even
three years after the launch of new
systems just as one example the ps4
released in november of 2013.
now call of duty ghost was the first
game to release on both the ps3
and ps4 the ps3 and xbox 360 would
continue to get the brand new call of
duty game all the way up until 2016 with
call of duty infinite warfare which
released on
only ps4 xbox one and pc if you look at
the history of madden it follows a
similar pattern
but these are of course annual heavy
hitting titles that are sure
fire sales juggernauts what about brand
new titles
sure there are numerous examples out
there but i went straight to wb's
history to see what we could find
let's look at middle earth shadow of
mordor this released almost a full
year after the launch of the ps4 and
still came out on ps3
and xbox 360 as well as ps4 xbox one and
pc
2015's batman arkham knight however only
released on the newer ps4
xbox one and pc so when we look to
recent
video game history it would appear you
can make arguments in either direction
on this
i can certainly appreciate the arguments
on both sides of this i really can
however i don't personally believe it to
be an issue of
fairness as some folks were saying in
the comments wb and avalanche
are both companies that have to make
decisions in their best interest from a
financial standpoint as they also work
to maintain a healthy work environment
and strive to make the best game
possible
if they feel that keeping this game on
the older generation tech
is really going to hold it back then i
can totally understand a move to the
current gen only
i also saw a few arguments that fans
wouldn't want to buy a new system just
for one game
by 2022 though and maybe even late 2022
depending on when hogwarts legacy
actually does manage to release i'm not
so sure how valid that argument will
still be
i mean for me personally there are
already plenty of exclusive ps5 games
out now and scheduled for the rest of
2021 that i'm super excited about
of course that number is only going to
go up even further in 2022.
all that being said though i do think
it's in the best interest of wb
to keep the games on ps4 and xbox one
i'll explain why for me it really comes
down to two
important questions number one how much
are they being held back by the previous
generations tech
look make no mistake about it the ps4
and xbox one were fine systems in their
day with some pretty amazing open world
games however
they're both known for having incredibly
weak cpus frankly even when they first
released those were weak cpus
now in 2021 and especially in 2022 these
cpus will be practically ancient
the ps5 and xbox series x have far more
power and it could potentially make
avalanches job
much easier if they didn't have to worry
about support for the old generation
tech
would they be able to make a drastically
improved game by focusing solely on the
current gen systems
considering that development actually
started on ps4 and xbox one
i'm not so sure that's actually the case
and unfortunately that's really only a
question that
avalanche would be able to answer
truthfully the second big question to
consider is how many ps5s and xbox
series x's will be out in the wild by
mid to late 2022.
they certainly don't have any problem
selling but short supply and scalpers
continue to be a pretty massive problem
amd supplies key hardware components for
both ps5 and xbox series x and their ceo
doesn't expect supply to catch up with
demand until at least
the second half of 2021 okay so let's
just say they actually
are able to ramp up production heading
into 2022 and they can actually get out
more ps5s and xbox series x's
is that a gamble that hogwarts legacy
can take of
locking out ps4's absolutely massive 100
plus million install base
at the end of the day that gargantuan
install base combined with the supply
problems of current gen will ultimately
result in avalanche
keeping their commitment to both ps4 and
xbox one owners
at least that's what i believe if you
all enjoyed this discussion and want me
to keep making hogwarts legacy videos
then make sure to hit that like button
before you go
as always guys and gals thank you so
much for watching i'll talk to you again
soon